allez dans l'est de l'ukraine à donetsk
où se trouve le correspondant de france
télévisions luc lacroix je vous propose
d'écouter ces dernières informations sur
le terrain donc à donetsk dans l'est de
l'ukraine
alors je me trouve à donner est que du
côté des séparatistes et on a cru tout à
l'heure à une accalmie et puis c'est
reparti de plus belle on entend de
manière régulière des bruits sourds ce
sont des tirs à l'armé lourde nous nous
sommes ici qu'à une dizaine de
kilomètres de la ligne de front vous
savez ça fait une quinzaine de jours un
que nous sommes dans la région et jamais
nous n'avions entendu des tirs aussi
nombreux le conflit est clairement en
train de changer de nature finie la
guerre je laissais désormais la guerre
tout court vous savez ici la russie est
généralement perçu comme un protecteur
tout à l'heure un habitant me disait
espérer la victoire de la russie ce
matin les gens semblent préoccupés mais
pas de panique générale ce qui frappe
dans la rue c'est qu'il y à des
personnes âgées des femmes mais très peu
d'hommes en âge de combattre car la
mobilisation générale a été déclarée
décrété elle concerne tous les hommes
entre 18 et 55 ans